See, I have a question for you, now.
>> Sure, sister. Yeah. So, if you you just
saw me passing, would you assume, based
off just how I look,
>> Yes.
would you assume that I pray five times
a day? Okay. For me, I would say on on
on on honestly
As-salamu alaykum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh, dear brothers and sisters.
As we watch what is unfolding today in
Gaza, we have to understand that
opposition is counting on us to lose
attention, to become fatigued, and to
move on with the new cycle. And just as
we can't allow them to dictate our
attention, we also can't allow them to
dictate the pace of our solidarity. And
part of that solidarity is going to be
there to rebuild Gaza, short-term,
long-term. I am proud to give my
support, my word of support to trusted
brothers and sisters in the United
Kingdom that have started a walk that
have started an endowment to make sure,
inshallah ta'ala, that we're there for
the long run. It's going to be
long-term, and we will not forget our
cause in Palestine. We will not forget
the cause of Al-Aqsa. And we will not
forget bidhnillah ta'ala our brothers
and sisters in Gaza. Jazakum Allahu
khairan. As-salamu alaykum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh.
What's your name, sister?
>> Rania. Huh? As-salamu alaykum, Rania.
>> Wa alaykum as-salam. Are you Muslim?
Yes. And where are you from? From
Switzerland. Oh, masha Allah.
Originally, where are you originally
from? I'm a part of the um Originally,
where are you from? Uh Algeria. Oh,
masha Allah. That's good. You know how
to pray salah? Of course.
>> Fully?
>> I pray five years of it. Alhamdulillah.
Masha Allah. Do you know anyone that
doesn't know in your family? Uh in my
family?
>> Yeah. No, they all pray, alhamdulillah.
Okay, good. Cuz we have salah mats for
free. But we give it but if you if
everyone knows
>> I actually have my friend who reverted
not too long ago.
>> Okay. Yeah, how long? How long has she
been a Muslim?
She I I think she took her shahada off
in the last 10 days of Ramadan. Really?
Wow, is this for Should I give it to
her?
>> Yeah, no no, it's it's for free. Yeah,
beautiful. Alhamdulillah. Alhamdulillah.
That's good. Alhamdulillah. Masha Allah.
You pray salah? Of course, I do. I'm
actually worried because I'm like, uh I
need to pray Aisha. Masha Allah. I'm
like, I low-key want to rush you.
>> know you know you know what's really
interesting sister? Um
>> Tell me.
We're live on YouTube by the way. Okay.
But uh what's your name? Rania. Ran-
Rania.
>> Rania. Yes. You know what's really
interesting finally cuz I always say
this to um
a lot of brothers as well cuz sometimes
you know brothers, Muslim men, when our
sister doesn't wear the hijab they're
like, "Ah, I don't know if I should
marry or not." And you know what like
you know what I say sometimes?
Subhanallah. Don't ever judge a sister.
Like for example, many people they see
you. The reason I asked you about salah
is because we have the project. Yes. I
have no doubt you probably cuz I I don't
know do you get it? I even ask the same
with hijabies. Of course. Even the
khabi. I don't I don't ever look and
say, "Oh, she's a khabi. She probably
pray salah." Yeah. And that's why I
always you don't know. That's the reason
I asked. I just I don't want to be make
that clear. But it's so interesting cuz
brothers were watching this as well is
that
of course you know you should wear the
hijab. And it's a it's a struggle for
you every
>> it's the goal of
>> May Allah make it easy for you.
>> Amen. The key is this though. For those
brothers out there who sometimes look at
sisters like yourself who don't wear the
hijab and be like, "Oh yeah, you know
she's not right for me to marry."
>> saying Let me tell you something.
Not only not only that, the fact that
you pray salah there are so many sisters
who wear the hijab they don't pray
salah.
>> True. To me it is a bigger violation
that you don't pray salah than not wear
the hijab. Because salah is something
the scholars have spoken about. And I'm
not saying I'm not justifying. I don't
want sisters who wear the hijab to feel
bad.
>> Yeah. I'm not saying that. My point is
this. We a lot of men judge sisters who
don't wear the hijab or sometimes even
if they dress in a bit inappropriately.
The issue is this.
Sometimes you see those sisters that
they have more haya. Sometimes those
sisters are more closer to Allah. They
have more taqwa because if you look into
the Quran, when Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
talks about taqwa, taqwa is not
something external.
Sometimes sisters who wear the hijab
it's easy for them.
For you the hijab might be hard, but
you've got your internal affairs more in
check.
When Allah talks about in the Quran for
example about taqwa, Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala says, "Taqwa is not facing the
east or the west."
Then Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala says, "When
you sacrifice the animal, it is not the
blood that reaches Allah, but it's the
taqwa. Then Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says, we send the clothing to cover
yourself. But the clothing of the taqwa,
the clothing of taqwa is more beloved to
Allah. Then Allah in Surah Tawbah talks
about Masjid Dirar. Masjid Dirar was
built by the munafiqeen to pretend it to
be a mosque to plot against the Muslims.
And Allah says, do you not pray in that
masjid, pray in the masjid of taqwa. So
when it comes from the to the place you
pray, to the direction you face, to the
clothing that you wear, to the animal
you sac- animal that you sacrifice,
Allah's talking about taqwa. Taqwa is
something internal.
And that's the reason why
obviously like seeing you subhanallah, I
just wanted to give that reminder for
people out there cuz I'll probably put
this on YouTube and Tik Tok or whatever
it is, that brothers, and I tell you
this, if you have more ghira, like
there's sometimes there's brothers who
come and say to me
"Oh bro, would you marry a sister who
doesn't wear the hijab?" I go, "Wallahi
bro, when I was looking to get married,
there was three sisters I was getting to
know for marriage who didn't wear the
hijab. I had one condition. They have to
pray salah. No salah, sorry. Cuz the one
who doesn't give the haqq of Allah could
never give my haqq."
But I'm not cuz I'm in the dawah, so a
lot of people think, "Oh wallahi, I
would say this, that and I know some
like
there was this brother that I met
recently, very practicing brother. His
wife's not hijabi. I wasn't like, "Oh my
gosh." Because as a man
Yes. And I look cuz he knows anyways,
it's not my thing. The point is this
is that sometimes subhanallah, those
sisters are more close to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. And that's why we
should not judge. Just the same way like
when we see a brother who has tattoos.
You cannot come and look, there's two
types of judging where people
misunderstand. Like I get this a lot.
There's judging from apparent. So when I
see you, I'm like, I can observe the
sister doesn't wear the hijab. If I was
here and I had an earring on, you'd say
the brother's wearing earring, he knows
that's not permissible. However, the
lines you cannot cross in judgment is
the following. She doesn't wear the
hijab, she's probably one of those
girls. That's a major sin. Oh, that
brother, he's got earring, he probably
robs people. Habibi, how did you go from
judging what's apparent, okay, that's a
sin, no wearing the hijab or having a
I'm having an in my hand. To jump to
then ascribe not wearing the hijab to
something evil. Or to me having an
earring or having a tattoo to I'm a a a
robber. Right. That is where people
don't understand
the the difference. So subhanallah it's
very important for brothers watching
this and sisters as well. Also for
sisters. Right. Don't judge men based on
their beard. Mhm. Or he has a thobe. Or
he says alhamdulillah 44 times. Mhm.
Don't ever when it comes to marriage I
don't know if you're married
No I'm not.
>> Okay. I inshallah I will tell sisters as
well. Don't judge a brother because
we're so superficial today. Everything
is external.
>> Yeah. Don't fall for a brother's beard,
his thobe, his alhamdulillah this that.
Cuz you know why? Sadly a lot of people
hide behind that. It's easy look I can
be someone that's evil. I just put a
thobe and I have a beard so I'm done. So
that's why it's very important
subhanallah for us to look internally
rather than externally. Sorry to give
you a lecture but I think it's a very
important reminder to give inshallah.
Any Any you would like to say to the
people who are watching this maybe a
reminder about Um Anything? If not don't
worry I don't put you on the spot.
>> I'm thinking. Yeah. Have you ever been
judged for not like wearing the hijab or
like See I have a question for you now.
Go on sister yeah. So if you you just
saw me passing would you assume based
off just how I look
>> Yes.
would you assume that I pray five times
a day?
>> Okay. For me I would say on on on
honestly my only thing was are you a
Muslim or not? Yeah. But let's say
Okay I am and you know this. Yeah.
To me it's like I don't in my head I'm
like okay
she prays. But I was like but what if
she doesn't? Cuz I want to give the mat.
Right.
>> concern is this. Yeah. If she doesn't
then I want to give her the mat so she
does.
>> reward you.
>> Nothing to do with that cuz my only
thing is when I see you because you're
not wearing the hijab I don't know cuz
sometimes sometimes you even get someone
you know Once I stopped someone she
looked like she was wearing the hijab
but she was a Catholic.
Yeah yeah so like I I was like well Yeah
their style is different.
>> Exactly. So so either way so to me yeah
yeah yeah of course of course. So to me
when I saw you I was like is she a
Muslim or not cuz I don't know cuz
someone get you know if you come from
all shapes and sizes. Yeah yeah that was
other than that to me let me be honest
with you. There was a Canadian sister I
can remember right over there.
She came
she dressed a bit inappropriately. She
was from Canada.
Something
in my head you know I said to her
and she was like you know brother sorry
I said sister wallahi I said not once I
had ill intention in the sense where I
thought bad of you.
I said can I ask you a question sister?
She goes yeah.
I said have you you've memorized Quran?
She goes how do you know? I said how
many Jews? Wallahi she's memorized 15
Jews. I haven't memorized that much. I'm
in the dawa.
Because you know why? Sometimes those
kind of sisters like subhanallah they're
struggling in life.
But 15 Jews of Quran?
Anyone that looks at her wallahi and
they would never think she's memorized
that much Quran. And the people
Exactly.
This is why that kind of judgement is
not permissible. She knows more Quran
than these brothers that would judge
her.
Doesn't mean what she's doing is right
but to judge her to that extent and
ascribe evil things to her is haram.
Yeah.
It was nice talking to you sister. May
Allah bless you and preserve you
inshallah. We are a charity. Our app is
called Salah Pro.
So subhanallah if you download it's for
free cuz the app is for free.
Yeah yeah. For your friend. For your
friend but also sister the the app is
also for those who don't know how to
pray salah. So this is the app.
It's got salah times sorry one sec.
You know for your friend she can book a
salah instructor to teach her to pray
salah. We have sisters instructors. So
salah times
you've got Qibla finder
Yeah with the tracker it's for free.
You've got your morning and evening
athkar. You've got tasbeeh. Yep you've
got your statistics like what you prayed
in the day.
Uh you've got videos as well for your
friend if she wants to learn how to pray
salah. It's all for free.
Have you sister may Allah bless you
inshallah.
Assalamualaikum take care. Beautiful.